assive,
hefty weapon.
This is the rhomphaia.
Wielded by the Thracians
as early as 400 BC,
it has the ability
to slay multiple foes
with a swiping blow.
Seems to me it'd be hard to have
both hands together on this.
You'd definitely
do some more damage,
which is, I guess, why it has
such a big, long grip.
-Try and get some torque.
-You get some torque on it.
Would you use this, also,
to kind of shove
your opponent back,
maybe against something,
and then
maybe chop them down?
I wouldn't do it.
Uh, you know, we don't do any
thrusts in this sport at all.
So we kind of avoid that kind
of, uh, that kind of gesture.
But with all the weight
that's up at the tip of this,
this is a superior
chopping weapon.
The root word
of the rhomphaia, "romph,"
uh, can mean
"to break" or "to tear."
And when you've got this
in your hands,
that's exactly
what it wants to do.
When you're
using this weapon,
if you can manage
to pull it back from out--
way outside
and drop it down,
dropping your weight down
on top of it...
it provides
a hell of a stroke.
With that being said
and with that technique
you just showed us,
you'd really have to get
some distance
to be able to land an effective
shot in that manner, right?
-Right, right.
-Yeah.
You're not gonna
see them, um,
whipping this around
in big, large circles.
You're not gonna see them doing
some type of winding strikes.
You're really just gonna see
them clashing against each other
and looking for
that super power strike.
Some of the most effective shots
that you're gonna see
are straight down
shots at the arm.
Ooh!
Yeah, that exposed arm.
A shot that comes across,
horizontal cut,
is easy to block.
You can show the block for that.
Yeah, just come in
against it.
If I came to the other side,
again, easy to block.
The mass alone can
ward off that blow.
What we want to do
is parallel the blade --
come straight down
onto the arm.
If he over-blocks
or if you could pump,
you can come down and come back
down to the other side,
to the other --
to the other arm.
Now if you get him to believe
that all your shots
are gonna be vertical shots,
that's when you can step in
and throw a shot
at the top of the head.
Ooh, nice.